-Thank you very much!
Hello!
[ Cheers and applause ]
And welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everyone.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for being here.
Well, guys, big news
in Washington today as Congress
finally passed the $1.9 trillion
COVID relief package.
That's right!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Most Americans are thrilled
the bill passed.
In fact, President Biden is
so amped, he just bit his dog.
[ Laughter ]
That's right, this bill is huge.
It's $1.9 trillion.
That's like a dollar for
every e-mail you got this year
that started with,
"in these challenging times."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, tomorrow,
President Biden will deliver
his first prime-time address
to mark the one-year anniversary
of the COVID shutdown.
Yeah, one year ago today,
many Americans left
half a sandwich
in their office like,
"Eh, I'll get it tomorrow."
[ Laughter ]
Yep, Biden's very busy.
Yesterday, he visited
a local hardware store
that received
a small-business loan.
And I thought his conversation
with the owners
was pretty interesting.
Take a look at this video.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What?
Later in the conversation,
this happened.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just found it odd,
but then he left them with this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
What's he talking about?
What?
Some business news here.
I saw that 7-Eleven is adding
something new to its menu,
and judging by the reactions,
it should be a huge hit.
-7-Eleven is adding a new item
to its hot-food lineup --
fish bites.
-Fish bites.
-I just think that's a bad idea.
-I have a very sensitive
stomach, so I just get worried.
I'm like, "Ooh, I don't know."
-I have never been one
to do fast-food fish.
-This isn't even fast-food fish.
This is 7-Eleven!
[ Laughter ]
-When the fish bites were
added to the hot-food case,
a 50-year-old taquito was like,
"Welcome to hell, bitch!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I know they've been busy,
but how does the CDC
let this slip
through the cracks?
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
But this is nice.
If you order the fish bites,
they just automatically
hand you the bathroom key.
[ Laughter ]
Actually, I'd rather
eat the bathroom key.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, well, this is cool.
I saw that yesterday
Timbaland and Swizz Beatz
sold the streaming platform
Verzuz to Triller.
I feel like that sentence
might be a little confusing
if you don't know
what those things are,
so here, let's test
that theory out.
It's time for
"Tell a Grandparent."
♪ -Tell a grandparent ♪
-Now, we arranged for one of
our staff members' grandparents
to join us on Zoom
so we could tell them
the news and get their reaction.
Bob and Margaret, are you there?
-Hi, Jimmy.
-Thank you for joining us today.
Are you ready for your news?
-Sure.
-Alright, yesterday,
Timbaland and Swizz Beatz
sold streaming platform Verzuz
to Triller.
-I'm sorry.
Could you repeat that?
[ Laughter ]
-Sure.
Timbaland and Swizz Beatz sold
streaming platform Verzuz
to Triller.
-You think that's news?
Call us back when Jay-Z
sells Tidal to Clubhouse.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oh!
-What? What?
I didn't --
That didn't go how I planned.
[ Laughter ]
Did they dab at the end?
Over in New Jersey,
I read about an Amtrak worker
who is being accused of stealing
some interesting equipment.
Listen to this.
-An Amtrak engineer
from New Jersey is accused of
stealing 77 chain saws,
103 chain-saw bars,
and 163 chains from Amtrak.
[ Laughter ]
-Luckily, he'll have no problem
in jail.
They're like,
"What are you in for?"
"Stealing chain saws."
[ Laughter ]
Every birthday, his wife
looks at her gift box like,
"Let me guess --
another chain saw."
[ Laughter ]
"Put it in the closet
with the other ones."
And, finally, a lot of people
are talking about a TikTok
that shows off one family's
DIY quarantine project.
Watch this.
-During quarantine,
my husband built a video rental
store in our basement.
Instead of refinishing
our kitchen cabinets,
he decided to build
a video rental store.
[ Laughter ]
-Meanwhile, their friends are
like, "I'm starting to think
that GoFundMe wasn't to help
with their mortgage."